however you feel about the lowbrow films
of Shawn Williams Scott it's hard to
deny that he's good at what he does
watch as we rank Scott's wild phography
from mess to best it's really more a
question of who isn't in the notoriously
bad movie 43 rather than who is so
perhaps it was inevitable that Shawn
Williams Scott would Pop Up featuring a
host of a-listers the 2013 Anthology
movie presents several interconnected
short films linked by the concept that
they're all movie Pitch ideas from
Charlie wesler played by Dennis Quaid
the real wesler prod the much maligned
film memorably described by critic
Richard roer who wrote movie 43 is the
Citizen Cane of awful Scott and his
Dukes of Hazard co-star Johnny Knoxville
play roommates Brian and Pete in the
segment titled happy birthday where the
pair fall a foul of a potty mouth
leprechaun and is equally obscene
brother both played by Gerard Butler in
a film that consistently plums the
depths of poor taste Scott segment is
one of the worst in corne Cox's 2014
feature directorial debut just before I
go Scott plays Ted who returns 's
Hometown to reconcile people from his
past before he dies by Suicide the
Larger than Life Scott delivers an
uncharacteristically understated
performance in this film and yet it's
his performance that leaves this film
feeling utterly directional shut my life
on the path to ruin and this is funny to
you you dried up withered old clam what
are you smiling about it isn't uncommon
for drames to take on some pretty
serious subject matter but this one
doesn't seem to know what it wants to be
or why at times formulaic and overly
sentimental just before I go also tries
to be a risque comedy and never quite
balances the two ideas more than perhaps
any other film on this list this one
represents the rockist comedy Scott was
known for and the more serious Direction
his career went in
afterward the reboot no one was asking
for the Dukes of Hazard took inspiration
from the 70s TV show but bore very
little resemblance to the original
series here cousins Bo played by Scott
and Luke played by Johnny Knoxville
along with their younger relative Daisy
played by Jessica Simpson stried to
protect their fam's land in The Wider
County from corrupt lawmakers we read my
name tag friend I noticed your initials
were uh Double D while the plot doesn't
sound dissimilar to an episode of the
hit show the film favors endless car
chases and gratuitous shots of the
famous short shorts over anything more
meaningful the result is something that
feels incredibly shallow and not even
the natural chemistry of Knoxville and
Scott can save it the whole thing feels
like a Shameless attempt to capitalize
on an existing property with little
thought given to its
purpose Stoner and slacker comedies were
a big deal in the '90s and early ODS
they brought with them a wave of iconic
double Axe beus and buad Bill and Ted
Dante and Randall all of whom meandered
through a haze of their respective
movies and shows with good humor and a
Carefree attitude however the pair at
the center of dude wears my car Jesse
and Chester don't belong in this
Pantheon of greats our protagonists are
two Bros who black out after a night of
partying and struggle to remember where
they left their car there's nothing
wrong with films lacking in intricate
plot details that is after all the thing
that often defines a slacker comedy but
but dude wears my car is so light on
story that it barely feels like a film
the film has one joke and it becomes
unfunny pretty quick if there's anything
good to be said about this film it's
that Scott and Kutcher are well cast
it's a shame the film gives them very
little to do Scott made his name in
comedies but in his later career he's
ventured into more serious dramatic
roles like in this Keo Reeves produced
2019 drama and already gone Scott plays
Martin the abusive stepfather of a teen
named Robinson tired of living in fear
Robinson runs away with his stepfather's
girlfriend friend an exotic dancer named
Kesha who'd also been abused by Martin
Robinson and Kesha are unlikely
companions but they find in each other
the hope of overcoming their shared
tramas or so we think Martin remains a
threat throughout and his reappearance
towards the end of the film provokes an
interesting conversation on the
codependency of abusive relationships
but the film doesn't take the time to
examine this the result is a film that's
as forgettable and fleeting as the title
would suggest Kevin Smith's films can be
an acquired taste this comedy however is
a little more vanilla than some of his
other offerings although it's not
without the director's trademark potty
humor copout focuses on police officers
Jimmy and Paul as they hunt down Petty
Thief Dave played by Scott who has
stolen a rare baseball card considering
the talent involved copout has all the
makings of a great comedy unfortunately
it's severely lacking in jokes and ends
up being painfully Bland as Dave Scott
has a handful of funny moments but his
sole character trait is that he's
annoying Jeff do you see what he's
doing he's trying to live here rent free
now don't get us wrong Scott can play
annoying really well but in this case
that's all the character has to offer
having worked with Smith on Jane Silent
Bob Strike Back it's easy to see why
Scott would be drawn to this film in an
interview with cinema.com Scott was full
of praise for the project saying I just
wanted to be a part of it because I'm a
huge fan of Smith and everybody in it a
film that sells itself on that person's
name is funny comes with the lowest of
expectations even so 2007's Mr Woodcock
manages to be even more disappointing
than you anticipate Scott plays John
Farley a best-selling author who shocked
to learn his mother is marrying his high
school gym teacher Mr
Woodcock that's called a takedown as a
boy John was one of the many students
victimized by Woodcock and the
experience spurred him to write
motivational books about overcoming past
traumas in better hands Mr Woodcock had
the potential to explore the long-term
impact of bullying and how it affects a
person in their adult life while still
embracing the absurdity of your mom
dating your former teacher
instead it features crass humor and
phallic jokes as John and Woodcock
compete in a series of challenges to try
and knock the other down AEG there's
some reconciliation between the pair at
the end but it avoids the Notions of
generational trauma and toxic
masculinity in favor of unnecessary
posturing perhaps we're expecting too
much from a film with a crude joke in
its title but it's disappointing
nonetheless every once in a while a film
comes along that not only makes a huge
cultural impact but influences the
Aesthetics of Cinema going forward
following the 19 1999 release of the
Matrix plenty of copycats emerged all
trying to emulate the flashy editing
mind-blowing martial arts and unique
visual style of the sci-fi classic one
of those copycats was 2003's Bulletproof
Monk featuring The unlikely pairing of
the legendary chaun fat and Shan William
Scott Scott plays car a selfish no- good
Nick chosen by a mysterious monk to
become the new guardian of a precious
scroll while there are hints of an
interesting Odd Couple dynamic between
Scott and Shia bold prooof monk is
extremely derivative and Scott in
particular feels wo miscast this is
America we don't have Enlightenment here
we have strip clubs Las Vegas and
HBO the film is shot like a music video
all style and very little substance
which is understandable given director
Paul Hunter's previous work David edene
writing for slate was particularly
scathing about hunter's Direction saying
he has no idea where to put the camera
for dramatic impact or how to move
people around in the frame over the
course of Scott's career he's appeared
in a multitude of copycats that pale in
comparison to the films that inspired
them such is the case with 2009's Balls
Out Gary the tennis coach a film that
shamelessly piggybacks on the Goodwill
of surprise hit dodgeball A True
Underdog Story Scott plays janitor turn
tennis coach Gary who tasked with
training a bunch of Young tennis players
there are pieces of the story that work
but it lacks The crucial element that
made dodgeball a hit likable characters
and good humor like so many of Scott's
films balls out is stupid and pural with
a shortage of good jokes adding kids to
the mix offers the opportunity to be
endearing and uplifting Bud balls out
instead relies on Gross out gags with no
heart to provide a
balance you can see the thumbprints of
movies like 2001's The Fast and the
Furious all over the straight to DVD
action flick where the former became one
of the biggest movie franchises of all
time this largely forgotten film remains
in obscurity it focuses largely on
Scott's character Ben McAn a man
indebted to some powerful gangsters who
assembles a group to pull off an
elaborate Heist using the noise
generated by a loud party as a
distraction given all that you can
expect this film to be noisy but the
never- ending pulsating techno track
makes it almost unwatchable still with
the G Nostalgia for all things 2000s
there's an odd throwback charm to this
movie that's so intrinsically of that
time largely panned by critics the BBC's
Neil Smith at least acknowledged Scott's
potential writing Scott displays enough
loose charm to suggest he may have a
future Beyond The Dump teen farces in
which he made his name not to be
confused with the 2000 Jason bigs comedy
loser American loser is a low-budget
black comedy that allows Scott to Branch
out a little from the one-dimensional
loud mouths he was known for Scott's
character Jeff was brought up in a
wealthy household but that doesn't stop
him from doing everything possible to
screw up his life work it to own it
because you're in it to win it relying
on his mom for money Jeff battles
alcoholism before eventually getting
sober but even then he can't seem to
catch a break his life is one mishap
after another when Jeff meets Lynn
however he finds his purpose and decides
to make a better life for them both as a
figure of ridicule trying to prove his
Worth Jeff becomes a surprising standin
for Scott himself and American loser
gives the actor a chance to show he has
more depth than his previous roles
afforded him while the film lacks Nuance
it is nonetheless a surprisingly
enjoyable tragic
comedy while Scott only has a cameo role
in this 2018 sequel it's certainly
memorable opening the film and what we
later learn as a dream sequence Scott
plays Trooper Callahan a highway patrol
officer who pulls over a speeding bus on
board he finds his favorite band
crackland bacon smoking weed and partc
when his partner joins him on the bus
the band members almost go them into
kissing F
[Music]
bus R shake your tail for see ass kiss
each other writing for the rap critic
William biani said the opening minutes
of the Broken Lizard comedy Super
Troopers 2 are so breathlessly funny
they might asfixiate you unfortunately
the rest of the film struggles to
maintain its comic momentum largely due
to scream in 1996 teen slasher movies
enjoyed a Resurgence in the decade that
followed and Final Destination remains
one of the best examples
in the film Alex is moments away from
his plane taking off when he has a
terrifying premonition the plane is
going to explode and kill everyone on
board after creating a scene Alex along
with some of his classmates and a
teacher is removed from the plane and
they watch in horror as the premonition
proves true the group tries to carry on
as normal but death soon catches up with
them Scott plays Billy Hitchcock one of
the students who's taken off the plane
oh we had to fight with anyone not only
does Scott have the best reaction to
seeing the plane crash but he has one of
the film's most iconic Death Scenes
narrowly avoiding being hit by a
speeding train before being decapitated
by a piece of shrapnel Final Destination
doesn't reinvent the wheel but unlike
most slashers the film lacks a mass
killer which gives it an air of
unpredictability and some ridiculously
inventive kills like scream Final
Destination had a good enough premise to
justify several sequels with Final
Destination 6 rumored to be in the
works Ivan wrightman's evolution is a
throwback sci-fi comedy that's cut from
the same cloth as Ghostbusters it's
Spectre destroy destroing predecessor
after a meteor collides with Earth
bringing with it an alien life form a
group of so-called experts assembled to
try and save the world Professor zra
Kane and Harry block are joined by
researcher Dr Allison Reed and
firefighter Wayne gray flyed by Scott
together they represent Humanity's Only
Hope Scott's character is very much a
fish out of water having witnessed the
meteor crash and now somehow along for
the ride it's the kind of role he excels
in the unsuspecting every man caught up
in an adventure he never should have
been in evolution is uneven in places
and pales in comparison to Ghostbusters
but there's still a lot of fun to be had
Scott doesn't seem like the obvious
choice to play a serial killer but maybe
that's what makes this horror mystery so
appealing from the outside Scott's
character Evan appears to have a great
life complete with a steady job as a
social worker a wife and a new infant
son beneath this seemingly ordinary
facade however he hides a twisted streak
inspired by his work with vulnerable
kids Evan embarks in a bloodthirsty
Revenge Mission seeking out and killing
the adults who abuse them Evan behaves
like a Robin Hood Grim Reaper playing
the a quintessential anti-hero by doing
away with people who've committed
heinous acts themselves while critical
reactions were mixed many agreed that
Scott's performance was the standout
element of the film variety Dennis
Harvey wrote it confirms that Scott
shouldn't have stopped starring in
movies when he aged out of the Cinematic
frat house in the latter half of the ODS
Scott progressed from playing obnoxious
College jerks to slightly more mature
characters 2008's the promotion saw him
take on the role of unassuming grocery
store assistant manager Doug stabber
Doug has his eye on the manager position
at his store's new branch location he
believes he's the best man for the job
but he faces some competition in the
form of new arrival Richard wner the
Rivalry between Doug and Richard isn't
mean-spirited in fact both of them are
likable and relatable characters despite
their flaws while they're competing for
the same job the pair are really just
competing for the chance to make a
better life for their families and
there's something endearing about that
as is the case with almost every movie
in the v Universe the World created by
Kevin Smith there's the sense that Jay
and Silent Bob Strike Back is one big
inside joke joke that not everyone is in
on if you are in on it however this film
will take all the boxes it sets Jay and
Silent Bob up in a meta adventure to
stop Hollywood from making a movie about
them Scott pops up along the way as
animal activist Brent and what you can
only imagine is a deliberate move on
Smith's part Brent chastises Jay for his
foul language in the vulgar way he talks
to girls indirect contradiction to
Scott's potty mouth rolls before he's
tricked into making allude confession
regarding
sheep 2000's road trip was one of many
films writing the coales of American
as body teen sex comedies go however
this is one of the better offerings
after making a huge potentially
relationship ending blunder Josh drags
three friends including Scott's
character eel on a cross crunchy road
trip to intercept an offending package
heading for Josh's girlfriend Tiffany
road trip might not offer the genre
anything new but there are plenty of
high jins to be had between the four
leads there's no denying that road trip
is low brow and Scott is essentially
playing Stiffler 2.0 but there was a
huge market for comedies like this at
the time and they're argu arguably still
is whether it's Jay and Silent Bob
strikes back or Super Troopers 2 Scott
has consistently proven that he only
needs one scene to make a Major Impact
perhaps the best example of this comes
in 2003's Old School when Scott has a
memorable interaction and mullet in a
scene with Will frell
yes that's awesome the film focuses on
three 30-some best friends who relive
their college days after attorney Mitch
moves into a new place following the
breakdown of his relationship the
concept of old school is in and of
itself but when you also have comedic
Heavy Hitters like will frell Vince
vaugh Luke Wilson and director Todd
Phillips involved you know you're onto a
winner in addition to all the runchy
immature Antics the film makes us think
about the idea of lost youth and how the
desire to go back to the Glory Days can
prevent one from growing up above all
this film is really dumb and very funny
and Scott's mullet is worth the price of
admission not for the last time Scott
and Dwayne The Rock Johnson prove they
have terrific chemistry in this
enjoyable buddy action movie movie from
2003 Johnson plays musclebound Bounty
Hunter backck who is tasked with finding
his boss's son the Shure Travis
played by Scott the film plays with the
classic one last job Trope and the world
weary backck is already over travis'
Antics before he's even met him
something that only serves their natural
Rapport The Rundown is a fast and funny
action ROM in which Scott once again
demonstrates that he's at his best when
he's playing against the straight man it
was also a sign of the greatness to come
from Dwayne Johnson his acting career
was in its infancy at this point who is
now one of the most bankable box stars
in
Hollywood whereas Shawn Williams Scott's
face could be seen everywhere in the
odds these days he seems to be much more
selective with his roles they may not be
as high-profile but he's taking on much
more interesting and gritty characters
as evidenced by his appearance in 2023
is the wrath of Becky this sequel to the
2020 film Becky sees the titular teenage
girl embarking on a bloody Revenge
mission after a group of incels attack
her home and steal her dog your brain
might immediately leap to John Wick and
you'd be on the right track as the wrath
of Becky seems to Delight in having a
similar premise however where John Wick
has evolved into a sprawling action
franchise this film keeps things simple
and the result is something that is Gory
fun and Incredibly cathartic the star of
the show is Lulu Wilson as Becky but
Scott is genuinely convincing as the
ring leader of the extremist noblemen
group perhaps like fellow '90s and odd
star Brendan Fraser we could be on the
brink of a Shan Williams Scott
Renaissance if this film is anything to
go by then that's a really good thing
director Richard Kelly's follow-up to
Donny Darko 2006's Southland Tales
baffled audiences and critics at the
time of its release set in an
alternative 2008 this dystopian movie
brings together a cast of Road
characters including action star boxer
cantos porn star chrisal and Scott's
corrupt police officer Roland toerner
and a mind-bending satire scientists are
saying the future is going to be far
more futuristic than they originally
predicted admittedly Southland Tales
isn't always the easiest movie to enjoy
and it's understandable that it took
critics a little while to warm to it
dony Darko was thematically rich but it
had a subtlety to it whereas South and
tales is the exact opposite it's
brazenly ambitious and requires multiple
viewings to try and unpack everything
but it's a remarkable achievement what
is equally remarkable is that Scott
appears in a film as out there as this
one in his dual role as Roland and
Ronald sner is undoubtedly one of his
best
performances American bu is
unquestionably of its time but it was a
huge cultural touch point in the late
'90s launching a Resurgence of the
runchy teen sex comedy in a big way Jim
Oz Finch and Scott's character Stiffler
are on the brink of adulthood but
there's a huge problem all of them
except Stiffler are virgins with their
hormones and libido's raging the film
explores the ups and downs of the
group's conquests often LED or perhaps
misled by stiffler's injections The
Unlucky and love quartet desperately try
to woo the girls at their school
Stiffler is usually on the periphery of
the main action but he steals the film
with some of the crassest and most
outrageous lines this was Scott's
breakout role one which For Better or
Worse became the the reason the actor
was predominantly typ cast in similar
characters for the majority of his
career nevertheless this film and this
character whom Scott reprised in three
of its sequels are what many still
associate with the actor and there's
something to be said for that to
continue to be true all these years
later the late odds were tumultuous for
Scott but for every dud like Mr Woodcock
and balls out there were surprise gems
like Southland Tales and 2008's Role
Models where the ambitious Southland tal
saw Scott stepping out of his comfort
zone Role Models had him back in more
familiar territory after a brush with
the law Paul ruds Danny and Scott
wheeler are faced with a choice between
a stint in jail or a community service
they opt for the ladder and find
themselves mentoring a pair of youths
through the Big Brother style scheme
sturdy Wings paired with the nerdy
Auggie and potty mouth Ronnie Danny and
Wheeler managed to learn something about
themselves along the way Role Models
feels like a wonderful full circle
moment with both Rudd and Scott now
older if not wiser than when they began
their careers starring opposite young
upand cominging talents the film still
has the vulgarity and immaturity you
expect but it also has moments of POS
that are surprisingly
sweet as hockey fans know fighting is an
intrinsic and entertaining part of the
game and there are often players who are
selected for their scrapping abilities
as well as their proficiency on the ice
based on the true story of Doug Smith
goon see Scott take on the role of a
nice but tough Doug glad whose mean
right hook propels him from the bar to
the rink the film pulls no punches it's
surprisingly brutal in bloody in places
yet it also manages to be incredibly
endearing transcending the cliches of
the sports movie genre to become
something completely different despite
favorable reviews goon bombed at the box
office however it's still widely
regarded as Scott's best performance
perfectly balancing crudeness with heart
and evoking genuine sympathy Doug isn't
the easiest character to portray and
he's a good distance away from some of
Scott's more one-dimensional characters
as well as having to convincingly play
Doug as a toughest Nails enforcer Scott
also has to portray a softer side when
that's polite and easy to root for and
he sells this
completely